the man sprinted through the hallways of
site-01 as fast as he could bullets
whizzed over his shoulders as Panic
shouts went up all around him the whole
facility was bathed in red as Security
Alarms deafened his ears he had to move
fast had to get out of here before it
was too late a force smacked him in the
back so hard that he fell onto his face
skidding across the vinyl floor planting
both hands on the ground and trying to
push himself back up he felt his right
shoulder blade creaking and bending
against itself he'd been shot enough
times in his life to know what a bullet
shattered bone felt like trying his best
to ignore the pain washing through his
body he kept running more bullets hit
him in his torso his shoulders his arms
and his neck one even caught the top of
his skull slicing a clear line through
his hair but he kept running the doors
were slowly closing in front of him as
the foundation Personnel swarmed the
hallways all he had to do was make it to
those doors slide through the Gap and
he'd be free if only they could
understand if only all the agents
researchers and the overseer council
could make sense of what he was telling
them they would let him go through these
doors instead of trying to shoot him
down like a dog just 10 feet to go he
was nearly there when a bullet ripped
through his calf and sent him tumbling
to the ground again but this time before
he could get up a rain of bullets washed
through his body igniting a pain so
Fierce that he wished it could all just
be over but it never was the pile of
pitiful remains was wheeled back into a
containment cell with a door locked
behind it you would think the body lying
on the floor was some kind of roadkill
but it was in fact a man a man whose
body slowly and painfully over the
course of four months pushed every one
of the 247 bullets out of itself and got
to work stitching itself back together
as he lay their weeping on his own
Andrea Twain had been headhunted by the
foundation while she was still in
college sitting in a Harvard Library
she'd been hard at work on her thesis
boring hour after hour into researching
jellyfish she was starting to see them
in her sleep and she was falling asleep
at her desk quite a lot fueled by energy
drinks and cups of coffee it was
starting to seem like the jellyfish were
floating all around her between the
bookshelves that's why when she was
approached by Foundation operatives
offering her a place studying the most
top secret entity on the planet she was
pretty sure it was all in her head but
then six months later and living in a
facility that she didn't even know the
location of it started to Dawn on her
the gravity of the task she had been
handed her research topic had been the
hydrozian turatopsis dornai a small
jellyfish with the power to reverse the
aging process dubbed the immortal
jellyfish she had been right on the
verge of cracking what was the
creature's genetic makeup that made it
able to produce cells younger than those
that they were replacing a feat that
could cure all number of human diseases
and revolutionize medicine and society
as we know it but standing at the window
in site-01 and looking through the glass
at
scp-001 Andrea realized that all of her
research had barely scratched the
surface of what was possible on the
other side of the window sat
scp-001 to many this SCP was probably
very disappointing to look at it wasn't
a giant reptile they couldn't teleport
around the facility it didn't even have
any visible powers or really anything to
distinguish it from any of the other
researchers sitting on the other side of
the glass it looked entirely like a
regular human male it was housed in a
standard humanoid containment cell with
no added security features it was
sustained on a standard humanoid meal
program Three Square meals a day with
the correct number of calories nutrients
and vitamins if anything
scp-001 probably had a more balanced
diet than Andrea herself did some
researchers have questioned the need for
feeding this SCP it was Immortal totally
unkillable and resistant to aging it had
been burned alive drowned in acid and
beaten to a pulp and yet very slowly it
would always recover so why did they
feed it if they didn't it would get
quite grumpy more than anything in the
world Andrea was desperate to talk to it
containment procedures were very strict
around this SCP there would be no
contact beyond the delivery of meals no
conversations no sign language nothing
it would sit by itself alone in silence
and three times a day a meal would be
placed in front of it by a researcher
who would promptly leave the reason
scp-001 could predict the future initial
Research into this SCP found that it had
an uncanny ability to describe events
that had not yet occurred despite having
no exposure to the outside world it
could predict an entire season of Major
League Baseball right down to the
individual player performances it
foretold the fall of the Berlin Wall the
Chernobyl mount down 911 the crash of
the housing market and countless other
events in 2004 a careless researcher
asked scp-001 what the weather was
looking like
scp-001 proceeded in detail to describe
Hurricane Katrina from its formation
through to the humanitarian response and
the political Fallout a full year before
any of those events unfolded the
foundation has tried and failed to use
these predictions in order to prevent
tragedies from occurring but due to
ironic twists of Fate any attempts to
prevent these predictions from coming
true often wind up fulfilling them in
the case of Chernobyl agents who were
deployed into the Soviet Union to work
in the power plant itself wound up
making critical blunders that led to the
reactor's Meltdown if the foundation had
not gotten involved the accident would
have been averted that said taking a
passive approach does not appear to be
an effective countermeasure either it
seems that whatever scp-001 predicts
that course of history becomes
inevitable how could you not want to
talk to such an entity as Andrea stood
at the glass watching it she knew she
had to hatch a plan the foundation may
not be able to prevent these tragedies
from occurring but surely they would
want to know what's going to happen they
were researchers after all and their job
was to discover information predicting
the future that was the most valuable
information of all but it went deeper
than that if anything the predictions of
the future were a byproduct in Andrea's
mind there was something suspicious
going on with this SCP something that
the foundation was trying its best to
keep under wraps she had seen it in the
classified documents files left out on
desks that should have been locked away
securely security and procedure had
grown lacks with the monotony of
containing this SCP and these files were
interview Snippets a chance for this SCP
to reveal who it truly was at the start
of the first interview Dr Lynch simply
pleasantly greeted scp-001 he replied
your daughter will be hit by a bus
before her seventh birthday I can tell
you the specific day if you'd like the
interview session was paused as Dr Lynch
grew distressed and had to leave his
post to go and spend time with his
family the interview resumed under Dr
Goldstein who asked scp-001 why he felt
the need to give such distressing
information to Dr Lynch he replied I
have told you people countless times
before you are not to refer to me as
scp-001 I am the founder of this
organization and you will address me as
such when Dr Goldstein questioned that
assertation
scp-001 replied you really don't believe
everything they have on file do you
address me as founder or I will tell you
about what your husband is up to Dr
Goldstein things collapsed very quickly
after that Andrea's plan started as so
many great plans do with her sprinkling
a chemical compound over one of her
colleagues Cheerios it was nothing
poisonous well at least not that
poisonous but it would put him out of
action for a few months long enough for
her to assume his position Andrea had
been next in line for a while to take
over the role of meal deliveries for
scp-001 and as her fellow researcher
violently vomited into a bucket in the
corner of their office she knew that her
time had come with the plastic tray in
her hands loaded with some kind of beige
slop and an apple she waited in the
doorway ready for the seals to hiss and
the door to slide slowly open for her
she stepped into the room trembling she
had expected the air in here to be stale
breathed and rebreathed for decades by
the same man but of course it had been
expertly filtered and purified by the
Foundation Systems the air in here was
as clean and balanced as it had been on
the other side of the glass the founder
looked up at her as she walked towards
him she would be a new face to him
something he hadn't seen for the prior
five years his eyes took Contour showing
no surprise at all she suddenly realized
that of course he wouldn't be shocked to
see someone new he could see the future
he knew that she was coming suddenly
unsure of herself she wondered what else
he knew about her future about her most
closely guarded secrets about whether
her plan would work at all Andrea placed
the meal in front of him silently
knowing that the cameras and microphones
were all paying close attention to her
subtly as she could she nodded at
scp-001 turned around and left the room
Andrea's heart hammered as she sat back
down on the other side of the glass with
her colleagues her entire plan hinged on
one thing monotony all of the checks all
of the vigilance all the scrutiny that
had been poured into scp-001 for decades
had to have Faded by now faded just
enough for the person watching the
security cameras not to notice one word
etched into the plastic tray as scp-001
took its spoonful of food now as CP p001
launched from its chair and sprinted
towards the door in the corner of the
room before any of the other researchers
could react Andreas slammed a hand on
the open door button there was a hissing
sound and the SCP was free from its
containment cell confused voices filled
the room yelling over one another in
utter confusion they had all been so
caught off guard that none of them had
paid attention to what had just happened
before they had time to put the pieces
together Andrea was out of the door
herself running down the corridor there
was just one door between her and the
SCP she ran over to key in the security
code to open the door and let the SCP
out but before she could even touch the
keypad a bullet caught her in the chest
and she collapsed to the ground wheezing
a scared security agent stared at her
wide-eyed what have you done he
exclaimed then both of them turned to
look at the locked door waiting Andrea
Twain had not wanted to let the SCP out
until she saw one specific line from an
interview tape scp-001 1 referring to
itself as the founder explained in
patient detail how it was entirely
supportive of the foundation's goals
motivations and actions it had no
intention of intervening with any of
their work it explained that all of
their ideas were in fact its own as it
was the one who had created the
foundation in the first place but there
was something coming a prediction that
scp-001 refused to speak out loud under
any circumstances it had just one
request that it would repeat to every
interviewer for decades after decade
they had to free it so it could prevent
that event from happening it must be
allowed to construct a device otherwise
while it actually never explains that
part neither does it explain what this
device is and point-blank refuses to
allow another to build this device in
instead due to the unpredictability of
what would happen if scp-001 was allowed
to construct this device the overseer
Council has Point Blank refused to
entertain the notion but Andrea just
couldn't and shake it from her mind this
SCP was capable of accurately and
precisely predicting all number of
future events right down to the granular
details no matter how tragic and how
dark yet there was an unknown in its
future it didn't know whether it would
be released or not it had to beg for its
freedom whatever it needed this device
to defeat was clearly so powerful that
it went beyond
scp-001's capacity to predict and
understand it there was an event coming
that was so significant that it created
chaos and uncertainty in
scp-001's perfect view of the future and
there was only one entity that Andrea
trusted to be powerful enough to
counteract this event and as she lay
there dying in a pool of her own blood
she looked up through the glass window
in the door at the entity she trusted
and watched as it keyed in the passcode
to the door the door slid open and the
SCP took off running along the hallway
with her dying breaths Andre told the
SCP the passcode to the door that it had
just opened understanding the Brilliance
of what had just happened the SCP had
been able to open that door because it
had seen the future where she told it
the password and with that she smiled
and laid her head down on the hard floor
except
scp-001 did not manage to escape it was
gunned down in the hallway with 247
bullets that brutalized its body and was
wheeled back into its containment cell
where it began the slow process of
healing for most of the research team
things went back to business as usual
albeit with slightly better security but
to the handful of researchers who really
thought about what had happened a sense
of unease settled on their shoulders
scp-001 would have known before it ran
out of that cell and attempted Andrea's
plan that its Escape was going to fail
it would have known decades prior to the
exact positions of the 247 bullets that
pounded into its body it would have
known the Searing Agony that it would
have to endure for months as its body
slowly healed from its failed escape
attempt and yet it had gone through with
it anyway what set of events had been
put into motion when Andrea carved those
three letters into the plastic tray what
greater purpose was scp-001 working
towards and was it now too late to stop
it now go check out scp-001 15 files
protected by a memetic kill agent and
scp-001u are the anomaly